ordered selections and another name for
these the sort of fancy name is
permutations welcome to part
combinations a bit later on but you guys
know how obsessed I am with the names of
things I'm just gonna let it sit for a
few minutes I will come back to it
formally or if I don't remind me I'll
come back to why exactly they are called
permutations a little bit later on once
we have a look at some examples of them
so here's where a scenario will begin
and this is the way excuse me a
probability question would usually begin
right a three-letter word is formed from
the letters a B and C and then a
probability question would then ask
what's the probability that if one of
those words were chosen at random that
it's a and then you can make up a
condition like what's the probability
that the first letter is a or the middle
that R is a or that the letters go in
order or something like that right but
clearly to answer any of those
probability questions you first got to
work out what is the sample space right
what are the total number of things that
you've got to choose from and then you
make that your denominator then off you
go okay now it turns out that asking
that question you know how big is the
sample space how many different ways are
there to do something it is kind of its
own category of question and that's what
ordered selections are about we're gonna
focus now less so much on on the
probabilities they'll come naturally
later on but just how many ways can you
do this thing right can you count the
number of ways you can do it this comes
in the sort of bigger category sort of a
super category called Arrangements which
is the other name that you'll often hear
permutations and combinations the topic
you'll often hear it called arrangements
so we're arranging items and here we
care about their order ABC is not the
same as CBA and so we're treating them
as different objects so how many
different ways is this possible now
here's a critical piece of information
that is missing that will define which
sort of there are two different ways you
could answer this question and it's a
piece of information you've seen many
times before do you think you allow
using the same letter twice well when I
give it to you in this form you have no
way of telling
one it is can you repeat repetition or
are you not allowed to repeat no
repetition and we're going to get two
different situations for each and we'll
do them each in turn okay now I know
this is going to look at this and say
why do we have to do this I'm gonna
hopefully in about three minutes show
you why I want us to draw because with
probability we would normally draw a
tree diagram of some kind I can't use a
dot diagram in this situation why not
well not practically anyway what what
situations do dot diagrams tend to be
useful in how many stages is a dot
diagram take care of we draw our
diagrams on a two-dimensional piece of
paper right so there's like event one
event two you know the first day the
second day flipping coins etc but I'm
asking you to work with a three letter
word here so instead of a dot diagram
I'm gonna go for a tree diagram in this
case if I allow repetition okay
let's think about what this will look
like this is going to be a bit of a mess
so I'm gonna cheat a little bit because
I sort of know what the answer is going
to be and I'm going to draw the diagram
sorry the tree diagram in Reverse
because often well you'll see the
problem that you can avoid if you do it
this way I know that when I choose my
letters over here I can actually know
how many I'm going to get at the end
because I allow repetitions it's three
every stage and even even having done it
somewhat backwards I've still struggled
so I'm just trying to make sure that I
have all of my different options with a
space and then here's my first choice
and you do this first one have you ever
had that problem where you draw a tree
diagram and you're like oh no I have no
space for anything by the end so that's
why these are really spaced out okay now
I've got all of my branches now I can
just fill them all in and you might
think wow this is a really
time-consuming process I didn't do it
really need to do this well there's a
really important operation that goes
underneath this that I need turn whoops
illustrate through this very expensive
and time-consuming tree diagram and
don't worry later on we won't need to
draw these things there we go
that's easier
okay now I could if I wanted to then
complete the sample space over here and
write all of those three-letter words
out but remember the question I had for
you before was how many ways can I do
this I'm just interested in the total
number the size of the sample space not
the items in the sample space good
morning
so if you have a look at this right when
you're going from left to right we've
done this before and you're reading
across a pro ability tree do you use
there's that key question again addition
or multiplication when you're moving
from left to right what do you do you
multiply across right we would usually
think say you multiply the probabilities
along each branch when you're going from
left to right now I can use that same
logic to think about well how many total
outcomes will there be if I got every
single one I think I did right when you
go from the first branch to the second
branch you go three and then you again
you multiply because you're reading
left-to-right by three options each time
write 3 times 3 and then when you go to
the last set of branches then you
multiply by 3 one more time right which
is why if we count out well this should
be how many options at the end how many
letters have I written down on the right
hand side I'm not asking you to count
them I'm asking you to think if I'm
multiplying each time 3 x 3 x 3 I know
it's early but your brains can be that
warmed up right that's 27 yeah by now
you should have been able to cut that
they were 27 okay so 3 times 3 times 3
that gives you the whole number of
permutations if you allow repetition
okay now over here if we don't allow
repetition mercifully our diagram ends
up much simply because we've got much
fewer options each time right so if I
still start out with my first set of
options okay if I choose a we're used to
this I suppose we could say I'm without
replacement right I no longer have three
options coming in out of eight how many
do I have just the two B and C because a
is no longer in the running same deal
for B two different options same deal
for
see two different options okay
I've selected two letters how long did I
want my word to be three letters so got
one more to go but here after you've
chosen a and B how many choices are left
well it's just one there's only one
letter to choose from so it's a bit of a
funny-looking a tree diagram you've only
got one option left
same deal with each of the others you've
only got one choice each time you just
have to look carefully make sure you get
the right one okay now this is small
enough that we can count how many
different options do we have at the end
what how large is the sample space one
two three four five six right six is the
size of the sample space and you can see
why the same logic takes you from here
to here I start out with three options
right and then for the next set of
branches I don't have three again
because I don't replace I don't allow
repetition right so it'll be three x two
and then once I get to that last stage
you still have to choose a letter to
have your three letter word but you only
have a single choice in each instance
right so this three cubed give gave us
27 these three times two times one we
have language for this right that we
learnt back in binomial theorem what
would I say here this three factorial
right and that gives us the six so as a
general principle if I did not have
three objects if I had n objects if I
had allowed repetition then I would have
n to the power of and like you do it the
same number of objects that you've got
and over here if you disallow repetition
then instead of m to the power of n
you're gonna have n factorial okay so
this is a general rule that you can use